Cut!
Roll camera, roll sound.
* Unheimliche, dramatische Musik *
Non duco.
No, no, no!
Come on! Come on!
# A poster child
for a love that is broken.
# I'm breathing life
into LA LA alone land.
Sie ist talentiert,
fleissig, ehrgeizig.
Und sie hat sich in den Kopf gesetzt,
in Hollywood Karriere zu machen.
Ich glaube, dass ich es schaffe.
Das ist so, daran glaube ich.
Und das ist der Grund,
weshalb ich weitermache.
In einer Welt, in der nicht nur
das Blut eine Illusion ist,
kämpft sich Sabrina Kern
konsequent hoch.
Wie will es die Sängerin und
Schauspielerin auf den roten Teppich
einer Branche schaffen, in der andere
einfach so über Leichen gehen?
* Unheimliche, dramatische Musik *
Davon handelt dieser Film.
Wie kommt eine junge Frau
aus der Schweiz auf die Idee,
nach L.A. zu gehen,
um eine Hollywood-Karriere zu machen?
Wie ist diese Idee entstanden?
Es entstand aus der Idee,
dass ich Anwältin werde wollte.
Ich wollte immer Anwältin werden.
Davon war ich überzeugt,
bis ich irgendwann merkte,
dass es nicht das ist,
was ich will,
sondern dass ich lieber die Anwältin
vor der Kamera spielen möchte.
Sie werden wütend,
wenn ich jetzt nicht gehe.
Dann werden sie wütend.
Auf dem Filmset
dreht sich alles um die Schweizerin.
Sie ist der Star -
ihre erste Hauptrolle.
Der Thriller heisst "St. Agatha" und
hat ein Budget von rund 1,5 Mio. $.
Das ist Darren Bousman,
der Regisseur.
Er drehte drei Folgen
des Horrorfilmklassikers "Saw",
die Dutzende von Millionen
einspielten.
You're gonna walk and then stop.
Der Amerikaner hat einen
hervorragenden Ruf in der Branche.
Für die 28-jährige Schweizerin ist
die Hauptrolle in seinem neusten Film
ein riesiger Karrieresprung.
* Unheimliche, dramatische Musik *
Während der vierwöchigen Dreharbeiten
wohnt der Star des Films
in einem heruntergekommenen Haus
in der Nähe des Filmsets.
Das ist die andere Seite
der Glitzerwelt.
Wir filmen
jetzt immer von 11-23 Uhr.
Ich werde nicht mehr
um 4 Uhr morgens abgeholt.
So habe ich Zeit,
mir morgens einen Kaffee zu holen.
Das ist herrlich.
Sabrina Kerns Gage
beträgt weniger als 10'000 Fr.
Um Kosten zu sparen,
teilt sie sich das Haus
mit Kollegin Courtney Halverson,
die im Film eine Nebenrolle spielt.
Sorry, it spilled.
- No, it's okay.
I'm sorry about that.
I gonna show him
my "St. Agatha" board.
Auf dieser Tafel
hat die Schauspielerin
ihre Emotionen
für jede Szene des Films erarbeitet.
This is what I'm doing tonight.
I'm doing the fever dreams.
So bereitet sie sich
auf den Drehtag vor.
Schauspielkollegin Courtney Halverson
hatte sich ebenfalls
für die Hauptrolle beworben.
Sie unterlag aber
ihrer Kollegin aus der Schweiz,
die viel weniger
Hollywood-Erfahrung hat.
Hasst sie Sie nicht?
Sie wollte ja auch die Hauptrolle.
Sie wollte auch die Hauptrolle, ja.
Das müsste man sie fragen -
in einer Geheimsprache.
Nein, dieses Gefühl
habe ich überhaupt nicht.
Hassen Sie Sabrina nicht,
weil sie Ihnen
die Hauptrolle weggeschnappt hat?
Wow!
He's coming in hot with that one.
Nein,
Sabrina sticht wirklich heraus.
Alle anderen Schauspielerinnen und
Schauspieler treten dahinter zurück.
Aber wir haben alle unseren Auftritt
und können uns genug präsentieren.
Auf jeden Fall
werde ich nicht versuchen,
dich hinterrücks
aus dem Weg zu räumen.
Gefilmt wird in einer Originalkulisse
im fernen Atlanta.
Action!
* Stöhnen *
Cut on rehearsal, guys! Stop
the work during rehearsal, please.
Sabrina Kerns Glaubwürdigkeit
und Authentizität
begeistern den Regisseur.
Die Hauptfähigkeit ist zu glauben,
dass es sich wirklich ereignet.
Das muss man wirklich,
denn sonst ...
... kommt es nicht rüber.
Man muss voll im Moment sein können.
Man muss im Moment sein.
Die Zürcherin
spielt eine schwangere Frau,
die in einem Kloster
gefangen gehalten wird.
Sabrina Kern absolvierte
die renommierte American Academy
of Dramatic Arts in Los Angeles.
Viele Hollywoodstars
haben dort ihr Handwerk gelernt.
No! No!
Still at that point.
* Schluchzen *
And ... cut!
2016 hatte sich die Schweizerin die
Hauptrolle in einem Theaterprojekt
von Regisseur Darren Bousman
ergattert.
Ihre erste Zusammenarbeit
wurde von den Kritikern gelobt.
Ich habe Sabrina
für mein Theaterprojekt
in äusserst schwierige Situationen
gesteckt.
Sie musste ohne jede Vorbereitung
mit dem Publikum interagieren
und den Raum ausfüllen.
Dann habe ich die Anforderungen
an sie immer weiter hochgeschraubt.
Und Sabrina
ging wie ein Profi damit um.
Ich realisierte:
Wenn sie auf der Bühne
solche Herausforderungen meistert,
kann sie das auch vor der Kamera.
Wir haben sieben Monate gemeinsam
am Theaterprojekt gearbeitet.
Für mich war schnell klar, dass ich
mit ihr einen Film machen will.
Es ist aufregend,
jemanden zu entdecken.
Mit diesem Film will ich Sabrina
einem breiteren Publikum
präsentieren.
* Fliessende Surfmusik *
Sabrina Kern lebt seit einem Jahr
mit ihrer zweiten Familie,
wie sie es nennt, in Los Angeles.
Alle vier
wohnen gemeinsam in einer WG.
Das sind ihr Freund Stee
und dessen Schwester Co,
bekannt als Indie-Pop-Duo ZiBBZ.
Cos Ehemann Yves ist Profigolfer.
Vier Schweizer,
die sich an diesem Samstagmorgen
einige Stunden Freizeit gönnen,
bevor sie wieder um einen guten Platz
im Scheinwerferlicht
der Traumfabrik kämpfen werden.
Alle vier
arbeiten hart an ihren Karrieren.
Momentan ist Los Angeles
der Mittelpunkt ihres Universums.
Doch das kann sich schnell ändern.
Wenn wir Glück haben,
funktioniert es
irgendwie einfach so,
dass wir es
am genau gleichen Ort schaffen.
Ja, aber das ist
in jedem Künstlerleben so.
Man muss nehmen, was kommt,
und auch dort sein, wo es kommt.
Früher oder später
klappt es oder auch nicht,
aber man muss dorthin gehen,
wo die Arbeit ist.
Darauf haben wir uns eingestellt.
- Genau.
Um möglichst günstig zu wohnen,
teilen sich die Freunde
ein kleines Haus.
Viel Privatsphäre bleibt da nicht,
zumal das Haus auch noch
Übungsraum und Tonstudio ist.
* Schlagzeug *
Gut?
Du bist mir
in die Aufnahme gelaufen.
Sorry, tschau.
Ich bin um ca. 11 Uhr dort.
- Ist gut.
Beim ... Ja, beim Petit.
- Okay.
Hat jemand von euch ein Handy dabei,
falls ich nicht reinkomme?
Ja, ja, ja.
Tschau zusammen!
* Schlagzeugsolo *
Nach unzähligen Hürden
hat sich Sabrina Kern
eines der heiss begehrten Künstler-
visa für Schauspieler ergattert.
* Popsong: "Hollywood" von Madonna *
# Everybody comes to Hollywood ...
Der Nachteil des Visums:
Sie darf ausschliesslich
in der Showbranche arbeiten.
Und gerade da ist der Stellenmarkt
besonders umkämpft.
Hier fand sie ihren ersten Job.
Sie ist ihm bis heute treu geblieben.
Einmal pro Woche
arbeitet sie für eine Firma,
die Dinner
in einer Originalflugzeugkabine
der Airline Pan Am anbietet.
Sie ist als Schauspielerin angestellt
und gibt die Maitre de Cabine.
Any other ... really?
Erfunden hat das Spektakel
ihr Chef Anthony Toth,
der eigentlich Spitzenmanager
bei United Airlines ist.
* Lachen *
Sabrina ist unglaublich lustig.
Wenn sie mal verhindert ist,
fehlt einfach etwas.
Die Durchsagen, die sie macht,
ihre Rollen und sie als Person
sind so witzig,
dass sie das Flugzeug
erst richtig zum Leben erweckt.
500 Fr. und mehr bezahlen die Gäste
für einen Abend in einem stilechten
Interieur aus den 70er-Jahren.
Ihr Chef erkannte schnell,
dass die Tochter eines Wirteehepaars
noch ganz andere Qualitäten hat.
Okay guys, wait, one second. Okay.
Deshalb koordiniert
die Schauspielerin nebenbei
auch noch den ganzen Ablauf
hinter den Kulissen.
I don't know if that will work out.
Meine Eltern sagten immer,
es sei sehr schwierig,
Restaurantmitarbeiter zu finden,
die so denken,
als würde es ihnen gehören.
Denn man arbeitet anders,
wenn man weiss,
dass die eigene Investition,
das eigene Herz drinsteckt.
Darum versuche ich jeden Job -
egal welchen - so anzugehen,
als wäre es mein passion project,
als hätte ich es ins Leben gerufen.
Denn so arbeitet man anders,
man ist engagierter.
Für diese hektische Schicht
verdient sie gerade einmal 150 Fr.
Und sie ist zufrieden.
Auch das
ist eine Realität in Hollywood.
(Mit deutschen Akzent) This is
Gretchen speaking from Germany.
And as part
of your Pan Am experience tonight
Air Hollywood is excited
to present you
our very own designer fashion show.
Der Höhepunkt des Abends:
Die Schweizerin
moderiert als Gretchen
mit einem extremen deutschen Akzent
eine Modenschau
mit historischen Pan-Am-Uniformen.
Yes, clap for the wunderschöne
ladies. Sie sind so schön, na?
Look at Betsy!
She is just the live of every party.
Sabrina Kern
besucht ihre Familie in Zürich.
Mutter Sissi und Vater Nicolas
betreiben mehrere Restaurants.
Eines der Lokale
führt Sabrinas Schwester Melanie.
Unsere Familie
hat einen sehr engen Kontakt.
Ich weiss nicht, wie viele Cousins
und Cousinen ich habe,
es sind auf jeden Fall sehr viele.
Ich dachte, das sei normal,
was es aber offenbar nicht ist,
aber bei uns sind alle Cousins und
Cousinen eng miteinander befreundet.
Sie sind mir alle sehr wichtig,
wie auch alle Tanten und Onkel.
Aber Sie sind diejenige,
die die Familie verlassen hat.
Ja, das ist verrückt,
man könnte meinen ...
Ich vermisse sie schon,
achte aber darauf,
dass es immer mal wieder
eine Familienzusammenkunft gibt,
damit ich sie alle
wieder einmal sehe.
Und sie kommen dann auch.
Ist es so,
dass Sie mehr oder minder alles
Ihrer Karriere,
Ihrer Vision unterordnen?
Es klingt zwar hart,
aber es ist irgendwie schon so.
Bevor sie sich
ins Hollywood-Abenteuer stürzte,
studierte Sabrina Kern
an der Universität Zürich
Kommunikation, Politik und BWL.
Die Chance, dass man
in diesem Geschäft reüssiert,
ist minimal, denn so viele Leute
streben das an, nicht wahr?
Sie ist absolut marginal.
Dessen sind wir uns bewusst.
- Das ist definitiv so.
Aber mit viel Fleiss,
Ehrgeiz und Drive,
alles Eigenschaften von Sabrina,
kann man es schaffen.
Und hoffen muss man immer -
sonst sollte man es nicht anstreben.
Ja.
- Oder?
Man muss es versuchen.
- Ja.
Sie versucht es
und ist auf einem sehr guten Weg.
Und wir freuen uns,
wenn sie es schafft
und wir irgendwann an
eine Oscar-Verleihung gehen können.
Gut, das ist ...
- Was kommt als Nächstes?
"I'm gonna thank
my mom and my dad ... "
Das ist Pflicht.
Noch ist sie auch finanziell
immer wieder auf die Unterstützung
ihrer Eltern angewiesen.
Ist es wirklich nur möglich,
so etwas zu probieren,
wenn, rein finanziell gesehen,
die ganze Familie hinter einem steht?
Nein, es ist nicht nur dann möglich.
Es ginge auch anders.
Es wäre vielleicht etwas schwieriger
und der Druck etwas grösser.
Es hilft sicher.
Aber langsam kommen -
Gott sei Dank - bessere Angebote.
Sie müssen mich
nicht mehr lange unterstützen.
Ich geniesse es,
aber ich würde viel lieber,
ganz unabhängig sein
und keine Unterstützung mehr haben.
Aber ja, mal schauen.
Und eine Mutter, die sagt:
"Die Kreditkartenabrechnung
war diesen Monat etwas hoch."
Ich bezahle sie selbst,
sie sieht sie einfach.
Nur damit das klar ist:
Ich bezahle sie selbst,
sie sieht sie einfach.
Du lebst schon
ziemlich back to basics.
Sehr bescheiden.
- Ich möchte nicht so leben.
Wir alle nicht.
- Trotz Unterstützung.
Sie lebt extrem bescheiden,
das ist definitiv so.
Ich lebe gerne bescheiden.
Dafür erlebe ich tolle Dinge.
Ja. - Ja.
- Ja, genau.
Zurück in Los Angeles:
Im gemeinsamen Horrorfilm
spielte sie die sadistische Oberin.
Heute will Carolyn Hennesy
ihre Schweizer Kollegin
für die Luftakrobatik begeistern.
Die Sache hat aber einen Haken:
Ich habe Höhenangst.
Ich weiss nicht, ob ich hochkomme.
Doch Sabrina Kern weiss:
Mit Angst und Zurückhaltung
schafft sie es nie in Hollywood.
Real tight. Let go with both hands.
Stretch out!
Oh my god! Oh my god!
Carolyn Hennesy
blickt auf eine lange Karriere zurück
und ist in Hollywood
bestens vernetzt.
Davon kann Newcomerin Sabrina Kern
nur profitieren.
Wie man Karriere macht in Hollywood?
Du musst ein guter Teamplayer sein.
Deine Aufgabe ist es,
allen anderen
das Leben leichter zu machen.
Und du musst lernen,
das Wörtchen Nein zu lieben.
Dieses Wort
muss dein bester Freund sein.
Du wirst es oft hören.
Ist Sabrina auf dem richtigen Weg?
- Keine Frage.
Vergessen Sie nicht,
ich stand mit ihr
vor der Kamera und auf der Bühne.
Ich hoffe nur, sie erinnert
sich an uns kleinen Menschen,
wenn sie ein grosser Star ist.
I'm a little person and ...
You know what I mean. Coattails!
Sie hat gerade einen Emmy gewonnen.
- Well, there's that.
Ready, set, go!
All the way up.
And ... one, two ...
Gegen die Höhenangst
hilft auch die Lobeshymne
der etablierten Kollegin nicht.
There you go.
Am Trapez gilt das Gleiche
wie in der Filmbranche:
Aufstieg und Fall
liegen gefährlich nahe beisammen.
Immerhin:
Hier gibt es ein Auffangnetz.
Ready? Set and drop!
Okay.
- Oh my god!
I was dying up there,
I wanted to cry.
Carolyn Hennesy
trainiert seit 16 Jahren am Trapez.
Für Sabrina Kern
ist dies die Premiere.
Erste Lektion: Nur wenn man sich
nach jedem Absturz wieder aufrappelt,
gelingt irgendwann
der berauschende Höhenflug.
Legs up! Legs up! Faster!
Got it. Hands off, turn away!
Legs!
Alright!
That's it.
* Lachen *
Alright!
# Marching to the drums
of my own little lone band.
# I'm breathing life
into LA LA alone land.
Um sich auch als Sängerin
im Showbusiness zu empfehlen,
produziert Sabrina Kern
ihr erstes Musikvideo.
Das Lied hat sie mit Freund Stee und
einem Schauspielkollegen geschrieben.
Die Regie macht Darren Bousman,
der Regisseur des Horrorfilms.
Heute ist die 28-Jährige
seine Chefin.
So you're saying the next shot
is with all four girls?
Yeah.
- Okay.
# Watch Hollywood acknowledge me
# then probably
you'll call in your apology.
Sabrina Kerns Budget für das Musik-
video beträgt gerade einmal 2'000 Fr.
Deshalb hat sie Freunde und Bekannte
aus der Branche zusammengetrommelt,
die bereit sind,
auf ihre Gage zu verzichten.
Auch das ist Hollywood:
Ganz viele Menschen
wähnen sich kurz vor dem Durchbruch.
Für diesen Traum
opfern sie fast alles.
You feel her backing away from you?
Take it all in your face.
Start to fucking lose it.
Das Scheitern
ist in der Traumfabrik ein Tabuthema.
Aber vielleicht ist gerade
ein gesunder Selbstzweifel mehr wert
als blinder Optimismus.
Es ist nicht nur
Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen.
Sehr oft rufe ich meine Mutter
weinend an und sage:
"Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich das noch zahlen soll."
Es ist wirklich so.
Es macht keinen Spass,
kein Geld zu verdienen.
So schön es auf Social Media
auch aussieht,
mein Leben hier
macht nicht nur Spass.
Es ist auch sehr schwer,
damit zu leben,
dass man nicht
genügend Geld verdient.
Woher holen Sie Selbstvertrauen,
dass Sie das überhaupt können?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Jene, die mich kennen, würden sagen,
ich habe nicht unbedingt
sehr viel Selbstvertrauen.
Ich weiss nicht,
aber es ist wohl der Glaube daran.
Ich habe immer ...
Ich glaube daran,
dass ich es schaffe.
Das ist schon so,
daran glaube ich.
Und das ist der Grund
wieso ich weitermache.
Ja.
# A poster child
for a love that is broken.
Got it?
- Yeah.
Ein weiter Karriereschritt?
- Ah ... Wir sind noch nicht fertig.
# Marching to the drums
of my own little lone band.
# I'm breathing life
into LA LA alone land.